el quinto debate de moción de vacancia
que vemos en perú en cinco años como se
explica esta aparente frecuencia con la
que se utiliza esta herramienta en el
congreso y que ha forzado la salida de
varios presidentes
como una gran inestabilidad política que
se genera entre dos poderes del estado y
que evidencian una disrupción y un
problema endémico en américa latina pero
principalmente en perú en donde en un
solo periodo de gobierno de hecho en el
anterior han habido cuatro cambios
presidenciales y esta suerte de
tradición del parlamento termina siendo
históricamente criticable en el sentido
y en el contexto que representa para
toda la inestabilidad general como el
seleccionar yo entonces para pedro
castillo en esta votación en particular
ha habido una aparente reunión
clandestina entre castillo con políticos
y empresarios que parece que le está
costando votos en esta moción
bueno en efecto lo que se necesita son
52 votos para llegar y solamente hay 3
partidos políticos que tienen una
postura clara en favor de la vacancia
sin embargo ésta no sería suficiente y
el presidente ha tenido
preguntas relacionadas a tener
concertaciones y reuniones en palacio de
gobierno con todas las fuerzas políticas
y la mayoría de ellas se ha mostrado en
contra de apoyar la vacancia y que bien
evidencia no hay el sustento suficiente
para declarar la vacancia es un contexto
digamos favorable entonces para el
presidente pero hablando de temas de
panoramas eventuales que consecuencia
tendría una nueva destitución de otro
presidente para el perú
en esta secuencia que sigue en la
sucesión sería la primera vicepresidenta
y única vicepresidenta porque el otro
vicepresidente no pudo postular por las
normas peruanas sin embargo esto traería
un desasosiego con la población podría
traer marcas en la última vez que
ocurrió y es donde el parlamento terminó
colocando a un presidente según la
constitución que lo podía admitir
terminaron abriendo revoluciones que
finalmente terminaron en el saldo de dos
muertes que fueron muy innecesarias
evidentemente hay una gran fuerza de la
población que quiere evitar este tipo de
inestabilidad política mientras hay
otras que están llegadas a quienes no
ganaron el poder político que se
encuentran a favor de este tipo de
medidas pero la mayor parte de la
población no acepta en sí la vacancia
porque generaría no solamente en el
impacto político sino porque hay el
peligro de la convulsión social y
también de una economía que está
luchando para reactivarse en un contexto
de pandemia y tenemos a políticos que
lamentablemente están constantemente en
un debate sólo respecto de sus intereses
y no el de la población como para
resolver los problemas principales que
tenemos en la actualidad la propia
reactivación económica el sistema de
salud y su integración son temas en
agenda que aún no están resueltos porque
lamentablemente hay otra agenda